محفل عسكري واسع النطاق في العاصمه
الهنديه قاده جيوش ثلاثين دوله يلتقون في
نيودلهي في مقدمتهم رئيس الاركان الامريكي
الجديد راندي جورج ونظيره الهندي مع
نجباندي يبحث الاجتماع التهديدات التي
تواجه منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ على وقع
تصاعد سعي الصين لتعزيز نفوذها هناك
هذه المنطقه ذات اهميه بالغه بالنسبه لنا
واعتقد انكم رايتم ذلك من خلال استراتيجيه
الدفاعيه الوطنيه هذه اولويه وجيشنا منتشر
في جميع انحاء العالم لكننا لتلك الاهميه
نجري تدريبات هنا اكثر من اي مكان اخر في
المحيط الهادئ تعهد جورج ايضا بالحفاظ على
منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ حره
ومفتوحه قائد جيش الهند الدوله المضيفه
مانوجبانتي اكد من جانبه ان الاجتماع
والتدريبات العسكريه المفتقره ليست موجهه
ضد احد الا ان استضافه الهند للاجتماع
وانخراطها في تعاون عسكري وثيق مع
الولايات المتحده لا يلغي خصوصيه موقفها
كحليف تقليدي لموسكو ولعلها بالتقارب مع
واشنطن ربما تسعى لمسك العصا من المنتصف
تترقب الصين بالمقابل اجتماعات وانشطه
عسكريه مماثله بكثير من التحفظ فوزير
خارجيتها
ستعارض ما وصفه بانه توسع متهور للتحالفات
العسكريه
صداع التحالفات العسكريه الغربيه يزعج
الصين بشكل مزمن وطالما حذرت من عواقب اي
مسعا لانشاء ما تعتبره تحالفا عسكريا على
غرار النيتو في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
وحراك واشنطن في هذا السياق لا يخفى ففي
اغسطس الماضي استقبل الرئيس الامريكي
نظيره الكوري الجنوبي ورئيس وزراء اليابان
في قمه تتجاوز الحساسيات التاريخ بين
جارتي الصين وترمي لتعزيز التعاون العسكري
في مواجهه بيجين وبيومبيانغ ليس ذلك فقط
فثمت تحالفات حديثه الانشاء مثل اوكوس
ويضم الولايات المتحده والمملكه المتحده
واستراليا واقيم في سبتمبر 2021 ضمن توجه
امريكي بجعل اسيا منطقه ذات اولويه
استراتيجيه قصوى هناك ايضا تحالف كواد
ويضم الولايات المتحده واليابان والهند
واستراليا اعلن قيامه عام 2007 واعيد
احيائه بعد انتخاب الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن اواخر 2021
تحالفات تترقبها الصين بريبه ومحاولات
مضاده تبقي منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
بؤره التوتر واهتمام لا ينقطعان